One possible answer is this equation. We're going to square this leg of the
triangle. Add it to the square of this leg of the triangle. Which is equal to d
squared, hypotenuse. This is really just the Pythagorean theorem. We have a
number squared. Plus another number squared. Equals they hypotenuse squared.
And what we could do is take the square root of both sides of the equation.
This would leave us with d equal to the square root of x2 minus x1 squared,
plus y2 minus y1 squared. Great thinking if you got either of the equations.
Now, the order of these variables doesn't actually matter, since we're squaring
the numbers. If we wound up with a negative value here, it would become
positive, since we're squaring it. The same is true for the y value. If this
value is negative, and we squared it, it would wind up being positive. So,
perhaps an easier way to think about it, is just, think about the change in the
x and the change in the y. How far did we travel this way, and how far did we
travel this way. We'll square both of those, take their sum, and then take the
square root to find the distance. This symbol right here that you see here is
delta and it’s a Greek letter that means change. You may have seen this in
chemistry or in other courses. And this delta just means change. I think it’s
easy to think about the change in the x values. And the change in the y values
to find our answer. This is more simple than writing this crazy notation.
Memorizing the formula is not so important as really understanding that we're
setting up a right triangle in space, when we find the distance between two
points. That can always help you problem solve.